today we're gonna try for australian
kitty for breakfast
my name is camila and i'm eight years
old my name's maya i am six years old
evan and i'm six otis and i'm six and a
half what do you guys like to eat for
breakfast ice cream waffle cereal
hi my name is jemima this is what we eat
for breakfast in australia toast
with a little bit of butter what is
butter we put butter on the toast then
we get a knife take some vegemite and we
put it on top cool yeah it's really good
this is going to be hard this is going
to be great
yeah we take the thing cap no we don't
put that
oh
oh this looks interesting okay knife
i never made food before oh god oh god
evan are you putting
summer in your hand
i need more butter
you just have to scoop them all around i
like butter i like butter too and
i'm a feeling you need some more for it
to taste pretty well spreading spreading
spread thin layer okay
this is a vegemite
oh my god it smells terrible it smells
like vinegar does it have vinegar in it
it looks like
chocolate chocolate but it smells awful
than chocolate it actually feels like
taking out nutella oh my god evan
seriously it reminds me of like jelly
and butter sand
well if you spit a lot it looks like a
chocolate sandwich look at this
okay
that tastes like salt it looks like
chocolate so i think it's gonna taste
good
okay are you sure about this event
here we go
that is super good
kind of like um toast butter and
chocolate
tastes like salt and pepper me too i
agree taste just the vegemite side
because you're just eating butter now i
like butter you're cheating still good i
ate the dark side no you did not there's
one huge gap over there don't stuff your
face into like
it tastes sour yeah it's not like
chocolate anymore tastes sweet sour and
better i think this tastes yucky yeah me
and evan like we only like the butter
this is how we would eat it in australia
a little bit of butter and then a bit of
vegemite on top
[Music]
oh that's much darker
good delicious i quit i'm gonna close
this thing i'm never gonna eat that
again me neither
we like vegemite
oh
no
i need to lick it okay i'm just gonna
wipe down my fan
you